"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" IS UP
NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU COULD NO
LONGER DENOUNCE YOUR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS AS RUSSIAN SPIES?
THIS IS A MAJOR PROBLEM IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY HAVE A SOLUTION.
YOU JUST CALL THEM WHITE
NATIONALISTS INSTEAD.
IT IS EVERY BIT AS STUPID AND
SLANDEROUS AND EVEN MORE
EFFECTIVE IN SHUTTING THEM UP.
BUT WHAT DOES IT DO TO THE
COUNTRY WHEN YOU WHIP UP HATRED
AND FEAR LIKE THAT?
WE WILL TELL YOU JUST AHEAD.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
HAS CONFIRMED WHAT HAS BEEN
OBVIOUS FOR MONTHS NOW, THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SPIED ON
DONALD TRUMP'S PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
NOTHING LIKE THIS HAS HAPPENED
IN MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
DROPPING THE NEWS IN PASSING IN
TESTIMONY BEFORE CONGRESS THIS
MORNING.
>> I THINK SPYING ON A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN IS A BIG DEAL.
IT IS A BIG DEAL.
>> YOU ARE NOT SUGGESTING THAT
SPYING OCCURRED?
>> I DON'T -- WELL, I THINK THAT
THERE WAS THAT SPYING DID OCCUR.
YES, I THINK THAT SPYING DID
OCCUR.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT IT WAS
ADVOCATED, BUT I NEED TO EXPLORE
THAT.
>> Tucker: THERE IS NOTE
DISPUTING THE POINTS THAT HE
MADE.
SPYING ON A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN IS A BIG DEAL
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT WAS RIVALED
BY AN ADMINISTRATION.
A YEAR FROM NOW THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION COULD LEAD THE
OFFICIALS IN THE KAMALA HARRIS
CAMPAIGN, IMAGINE IF CAUGHT, HE
POINTED TO THE OPPOSITION
RESEARCH GENERATED BY THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE AS
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT
SURVEILLANCE.
HOW WOULD WE REACT?
LIKE IT WAS A MAJOR DRAW
DROPPING SCANDAL, AND THIS THAT
SHOW WOULD AGREE WITH THAT, WE
WOULD NOT AGREE WITH THAT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD NEVER BE
USED AS A PARTISAN POLITICAL
TOOL, NO MATTER WHO IT BENEFITS.
BUT THE MEDIA DOES NOT FEEL THAT
WAY ABOUT OBAMA.
THEY REFUSE TO ADMIT THAT THERE
WAS SPYING, JENNIFER RUEB ARE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ATTACKED
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
BRINGING UP THE TOPIC AT ALL.
SHE CALLED BARR
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TOADY.
CNN SAYS THAT THERE IS LITTLE
EVIDENCE THAT SPYING ACCORD, BUT
THERE -- THAT IS A LIE, THERE IS
PLENTY OF EVIDENCE THAT SPYING
OCCURRED.
IN 2016 AND 2017, THEY
WIRETAPPED PAUL MANAFORT, THE
FORMER CHAIRMAN.
CARTER PAGE WAS SPIED ON
EXTENSIVELY BY THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
OBVIOUS FROM THE VERY FIRST DAY
THAT HE WAS NOT A RUSSIAN SPY.
LAST YEAR WE LEARNED THAT THE
FBI USED AN INFORMANT TO FEUD
INFORMATION INSIDE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS ALL SPYING.
THERE IS NO OTHER WORD FOR IT.
WHEN TRUMP COMPLAINED ABOUT
BEING SPIED ON, DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES IN THE MEDIA
CALLED HIM A NUTCASE AND A LIAR.
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT ANY ALLEGATION THAT THE
FBI OR ANY INTELLIGENCE AGENCY
PLACED A SPY IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> THESE BASELESS CLAIMS OF
SPIES.
>> THE SO-CALLED SPY ISSUE.
FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE THAT
THERE WAS A SPY.
SO IT IS REALLY A FAKE ISSUE.
>> THE PHONY BALONEY STORY ABOUT
A SPY IN THE CAMPAIGN.
TO CALL IT A CONSPIRACY THEORY
IS TO GIVE IT TOO MUCH CREDIT.
TO FAKE FACTS.
>> YOU SEE THE INTELLIGENCE AND
YOUR OWN PARTY IS SAYING THAT
THERE IS JUST KNOW THEY ARE
THERE.
I'M WONDERING WHAT IT WILL TAKE
FOR YOU CONGRESS MEANT TO SAY IS
FULL OF IT.
>> Tucker: HE LIED, HE IS
CRAZY, A LOT OF REPUBLICAN SAID
THAT TOO, BY THE WAY.
WE SHOULD REMEMBER THEIR NAMES.
AS IT TURNS OUT, THERE WAS IN
FACT A CONSPIRACY TO HIDE THE
TRUTH.
BUT TRUMP WAS NOT LEAVING THAT
CONSPIRACY, JIM CLAPPER WAS.
>> WAS THE FBI SPYING ON TRUMP
CAMPAIGN?
>> NO, THEY WERE NOT.
THEY WERE SPYING ON A TERM THAT
I DO NOT LIKE IT, BUT WHAT THE
RUSSIANS WERE DOING, TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE RUSSIANS
INFILTRATING TRYING TO GAIN
ACCESS AND LEVERAGE AND
INFLUENCE.
>> WHY DOES HE NOT LIKE THAT?
>> HE SHOULD BE.
>> Tucker: HE SHOULD BE, YOU
GOT THAT, THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT SPYING,
THEY WERE WATCHING HIM WITHOUT
HIS KNOWLEDGE COULD ON
BEHALF OF THE OPPOSING PARTY IN
THE CLOSING MONTHS OF A BITTER
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
NO BIG DEAL.
TRUMP SHOULD BE GRATEFUL FOR
THAT.
THEY CARED ENOUGH TO SURVEILLED
HIS STAFF.
THEY ARE PATRIOTIC THAT WAY,
THEY ARE BIGHEARTED PEOPLE.
COME ON, THERE HAS TO BE A LIMIT
TO HOW MUCH LYING A COUNTRY CAN
TAKE FROM THEIR LEADERS BEFORE
THINGS FALL APART.
AND WE HAVE REACHED OUR LIMIT.
RUSSIAN COLLUSION DID NOT HAPPE
HAPPEN.
DOMESTIC SPYING DURING A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN DID
HAPPEN, AND WE HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW WHO PARTICIPATED IN IT.
WHO AUTHORIZED IT.
AND WHAT THEIR MOTIVES WERE.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW THAT
IMMEDIATELY, WITHOUT REDACTION.
TO THE COUNTRY NOT BELONG TO
RETIRED OBAMA STAFFERS AND INTEL
AGENCY HEADS AND MINDLESS CNN